salut les amis on est là pour parler de
michael de vaud qui est un chouchou de
longue date du présentateur de ce
podcast et qui a donc réussi finalement
à attirer la lumière sur lui et à en
faire un portrait de draft et pour ce
nouvel épisode qui nous mène petit à
petit vers vers la draft vous avez sur
notre site le big board qui est sorti
donc le classement de nos meilleurs
prospects michael de vaud n'est pas dans
le top 30 mais metz pourrait qu'il ne
soit pas très très loin on va voir
évidemment ses qualités ses défauts sa
carte d'identité dans un premier temps
et puis ensuite on va poser les
questions sur sa projection dans la
deuxième partie et pour ça un trio de
choc puisque nous avons alan ben et
steve salut messieurs bonsoir bonsoir
alors michael de vaud j'ai pas j'ai pas
trouvé de vannes à faire sur sur son jeu
de mots mais je compte sur vous sur son
blog sur ce jeu de mots à faire sur son
sur son patronyme je compte sur vous
pour la suite du podcast en attendant on
va lancer le générique tout de suite
[Musique]
carte d'identité
michael de vos joueurs georgia tech
steve c'est toi qui tu occupes de nous
présenter le parcours de ce monsieur qui
est il qu elle age at il devient t-il
est ce qu'il a un chien voilà où michael
niveau comme tu l'as dit jour yeoh
jacquet était qu un arrière est dans sa
quatrième année senior il est né le 17
décembre 1999 orlando floride dans la
ville du magic a commencé le basket à 9
ans il fait trois années de high school
à orlando à la oak ridge et sa dernière
année à montverdun pas toujours en
floride où il va côtoyer notamment air
djebar est philippe et rousseff en
trinôme barbe fini champion national
pourtant vaincu 35 victoires pour 0
défaite
autre quatre étoiles ou mytho
yellowjacket
oufir à mesure il est devenu un des
joueurs les plus importants de l'équipe
pour être aujourd'hui le leader de
l'équipe il a un oncle des zones mal
whif il a joué à sofia obama qui a été
produit soit là pour le background un
peu sportif et moi ça c'est beau fallait
le trouver l'oncle qui a joué en suisse
tu sais dans quelles villes de suisse ou
pas à retrouver
ok il nous prend ça pour pour plus tard
on sait de qui on parle ça c'est très
bien on sait qu'on parle d'un joueur
poste aller 2-3 mais on va parler de son
corps et ça c'est ben qui s'en occupent
peine que nous dit le corps de michael
ii vous
européen michael de haut et un mètre 96
82 kg on avait les 15 110 pieds cinq
pouces et 191 livres je n'ai pas son
envergure en son sein des riches ce qui
est un peu moins grave de son côté mais
j'ai une information intéressante ici
c'est un gaucher donc c'est quelque
chose qui est un peu plus rares donc de
plus difficile à deschamps ce qui est
vraiment une carte intéressant pour lui
en nba
pas une énorme athlète
je trouve ce propos quelqu'un qui est
explosif pour quelqu un qu une grande
radicalité il n'est pas mauvais
horizontalement il se déplace bien et
bouge vite mais on parle pas ici de
quelqu'un qui qui qui défonçaient
annoncé l'insee
c'est correct si les 22 ans donc pas un
gros passé de la sueur non plus
le plus gros ch
la grosse période de tak prix c'est
quand qu'ils étaient dans les protocoles
que vides de georgia tech l'année
dernière et il n'avait pas la cause est
juste une mesure préventive il avait
testé négatif la première et la dernière
fois donc on a ici avec michael de vaud
un profil physique qui est ma foi
très cependant très commun qui se
démarquent fort mais comme on vous
parlait plus tard d'un podcast c'est pas
à cause de ça qu'on vende l'arctique
surtout pas connaissance effectivement
ben tu as raison et nous avons
l'information steve est ce que tu peux
me donner le nom de la commune je suis
en train de google maps et tous à
massagno ou à jouer l'oncle
ok bah il a bien choisi son coin de la
suisse puisque c'est à côté de lugano
superbe blake superbes paysages à près
de la frontière italienne doit bien
manger bravo à l'oncle de michael de
vaud pour ces chouettes qui a réussi à
l'européenne
donc ben nous disait on va pas drafté
michael de vaud pour son corps alors
pourquoi on va le draft et la question
pour toi à l'année on va gratter parce
que sans rien faire d'exceptionnel c'est
a pas eu de tirs extérieurs c'est un
joueur qui sur un terrain je pense
d'emblée en nba peut être inséré ne pas
faire d'erreur ne pas pénaliser trop son
équipe parce que c'est un genre mur en
sortir chez crest attendant mange tout
et je te parle 3408 hennetier qui a
start et alors on parle 90 matchs qui a
toujours été titulaire quasiment dans
ses quatre saisons à georgia tech cam un
rôle exponentielle changeant le tout en
devenant de plus en plus efficace c'est
un joueur mature c'est un jour qui sait
ce qu'il sait faire il le fait bien et
qui s'améliore d'année en année donc il
a vraiment le profil parfait je pense du
solide jours de rotation en billets
alors si on doit comparer à un joueur
récent et qui a du succès en nba au
niveau des mensurations et même du
profil on peut comparer austin risque
quasiment les mêmes mensurations et qui
avait aussi québec avait aussi fait un
cursus de quatre ans que l'on a et qui a
un rôle dès sa première année aux lakers
donc voilà
ah bon à bon entendeur
j'ai besoin de vous poser des questions
néanmoins sur michael de vaud puisque
vous le savez toute la question ça va
être est ce qui va shooter suffisamment
bien pour avoir du temps de jeu en gros
c'est ça donc à quel point vous croyez
en lui gros shooter est ce que vous
pouvez me disséquer son tir je commence
par toi steve qu'est ce que tu aimes
dans ce tir qu'est ce qu'il ya à revoir
est ce qu'il ya une diversité est ce que
il ya des appuis qui sont toujours bien
bien positionné bien un bien en rythme
est-ce qu'il a des particularités c'est
à dire que j'ai tout mis en mouvement ou
skis shoot mieux ans en posant droite
gauche plutôt gauche droite voilà est-ce
qu'il ya des choses que tu as remarqué
chez lui qui pourrait faire capoter la
chose ou au contraire faire réussir sa
carrière nba moi je suis très confiant
sur la qualité de son tir je pense que
il est capable de tirer dans plusieurs
contextes lui assure une pièce
différente les capable d'être sûr du
temps du catch and shoot ou capable de
tirer en mouvement à sortie d'écran la
capacité à tirer en sortie de dribble
puis sur transition peut-être pour ses
clients son propre tir en tout cas il
est capable de tirer sur transition avec
du gris bhl et puis là une vraie
distance nba qu'il va retirer du noir et
vite donc moi je suis assez confiant sur
la capacité à trois très bons tireurs au
nba ben est ce que tu rejoins cette
affirmation est pareil sur la technique
est ce que tu as des des choses à redire
oui c'est un joueur qui une motion de
tir de en deux temps donc ça c'est
peut-être la seule chose qui leur permet
comme je disais steve sont ridge et
allemand font et défont et amorphe au
fond
des filets
à venir le chercher c'est un beau
passage donc il va être capable de
donner de donner du fil à retordre aux
défenses de cette manière là non moi j'y
crois un michael devos et l'emploi de
joie qui passe absolument sous le radar
puis qui se fait grâce était beaucoup
trop tôt par une équipe qui a fait six
ans qui a fait ses devoirs puis qui qui
vont enfin avoir leur tour tous le reste
des gens de db s'il part s'ils vont
avoir fait le bon choix alors que
personnel moi j'y crois un michael de
vous surtout dans un petit rôle dans un
but précis a oublié de schubert qui va
adam ii dans plusieurs situations en
sortie de crise en pleurs plus ces
choses comme ça moi j'y crois vraiment
un lieu place un billet pour lui à
l'année ce qui peut faire autre chose
une fois qu'on lui a contesté le tir une
fois que l'équipe adverse aura fait son
travail de scouting d'avant match et
qu'on va sortir sur ses tentatives est
ce qu'il va être capable de faire
quelque chose du ballon et l'afda c'est
un des trucs les plus intéressants je
trouvais bien eu sous-évalué quand on
parle de ses profits sur les extérieurs
c'est pourcentage à 2 points et en fait
on voit que c'est un joueur qui ont
carrière à 49% à 2 po et à 54 % cette
année donc ça veut dire que en réalité
qu à accéder quand même un petit peu
haussière qui peut poser le ballon au
sol il peut prendre mes distances il à
40% sur les mi-distance cette année non
il avait 40 pour cent pas sur ça pour
moi c'est ça dont 25% se sont assises et
donc les trois quarts de ce décret le
gabon peut être que c'est aux clauses à
votre fort sur lui car de poser un
dribble et après s'est levé pour un
minerai de la mi distance alors c'est
pas sûr qu'on lui demande un tel sens
nba comme l'a dit bête des
spécialisations très rapide mais il est
capable de ça moi le pointage à deux
points je trouve que c'est quelque chose
dont on a tendance à sous côté on sûr
qu'opel pourcentage à 3 ans mais il sait
aussi important pouvoir accéder aux
serres pouvoir mettre des flotteurs
pouvoir ne pas être ultra dépendant de
son adresse à trois points parce que
sinon on devient pas
peut devenir un peu ce qui
était lé profil un peu différent mais
des joueurs comme des ventes est grave
il manuel coûte l'est où des joueurs
comme ça copyright bas eux ils sont
vraiment comme ils ont beaucoup de mal à
finir 12.1 finir auxerre et ben euh ils
sont vraiment dans la pure adresse à
trois points mais si l'on regarde les
pourcentages au tir souvent c'est aux
dans les 30 % à 3 points mais c'est
aussi donner 30 % à 2 points en réalité
c'est à dire que tu as même quasiment un
tiers de tenir un petit être sûr que tu
mets pas ce que me2 vaut peut être plus
atteint 43 44 45 % aux tirs globale ce
qui pourrait le rendre je trouve
efficace dans la rotation d'unique
il est d'une régularité rare aux lancers
francs mais pas dans le bon sens du
terme pour moi puisque ça fait trois
saisons de suite qui shoote à 75 % ce
qui est pas du tout signe d'un
d'une mécanique
élite et d'un shoot élite steve est ce
que tu as ta des explications à sa non
pas tellement effectivement très curieux
et je n'ai pas d'explication rationnelle
sur le petit haut pourcentage est
peut-être une dimension mentale je ne
suis pas la seule piste que je vois est
il à 40% à 3 pro carrière que ouais
ouais bien sûr sûr sûr
presque 500 tentative y est presque à
41% donc c'est énorme oui bien sûr et
d'ailleurs y aille il ya eu un article
qui est sorti récemment et je vais pas
être capable de citer le site mais si
vous le demandez je pourrais mettre le
lien sur les réseaux sociaux qui disait
que après moult calculs le
critère le plus déterminant enfin en
tout cas la plus grande corrélation
entre les stades de foot n 6 et les
stades de shoot nba c'était quand même
le pourcentage à 3 points donc donc ça
veut dire qu'il a quand même de bonnes
chances d'être d'être un bon shooteur à
trois points en tout cas de ne pas être
médiocre puisqu'il aura besoin d'être
forcément bon pour jouer mais en début
d'année
lors je sais plus quel que je disais ça
il disait en nba tu peux jouer que si tu
sait défendre roman une position est
alors moi j'ai regardé des matches comme
vous peut-être moins mais j'ai pas vu un
michael de vaud qui était capable de
défendre avec une grande efficacité
une position en particulier steve houben
allez-y les uns après les autres sur sur
la défense de michael de vous il ya
beaucoup de baisers il ya beaucoup de
désir de défendre une certaine d'exister
car il est femme un nom oui je pense
assez limité sur les circuits comme
je crois que toujours au moins un joueur
sur le terrain pour défendre sied à une
glisse que ça va être le coeur
du lait soit définitivement pas tous les
soirs je crois que justement il vaut
peut-être avoir à gagner
à faire un peu de j-league personne ne
peut mettre son jeu à niveau mais oui la
vitesse latéral les pieds parfois ça
s'emballe les gens
comme distinguer le psy donc
s'asseoir sur un gros point
d'interrogation pour le pour le niveau
suivant comme des spaghettis donc stif
ici
pour la défense de michael de voix de
georgia tech qui mixe
individuels zone ils font parle de
défenses différentes
exactement mais parfois ils les font
tourner à la zone parfois sur la normale
il est il est intéressant sur la défense
collective par contre alors que là
dessus il est concentré sur les
rotations là une vraie activité de bras
mais effectivement je pense qu'en nba du
fait de ces limitations physiques frais
seront ciblés et aujourd'hui c'est plus
un poste 2 et c'est vrai que quand on
compare à des postes de n'diaye pense
qu'il aura du mal à tenir à tenir ces
rencontres effectivement qui sera ciblé
parce que physiquement il est aisé il
est trop faible donc la sarre a eu
l'effet négatif à l'année ce qu'on peut
quand même joué est-ce qu'on peut cacher
un joueur comme ça et ce qui va vraiment
être ciblé ce que ça arrive vraiment à
une billets que cinq attaques de suite
il ya un joueur adverse qui soient
ciblées comme ça bah écoute samedi j'ai
vu max truths tiger heroes et duncan
robinson jouer ensemble
et ils ont gagné à phoenix et
franchement si tu tournes 11 ans et
franchement ça allait donc si tu tombes
dans un bon environnement
avec une un coach qui a un peu créatif
et surtout très fort juin d'un très fort
protecteur de cercle parce qu'en fait
c'est quoi au mériot stevans est pas
meilleur protecteur de cercle organise
bêtement on est on est d'accord mais en
fait c'est quoi le problème de 2 go
c'est que moi je trouve c'est que sur le
banc et d'enfants attaque il peut pas
tenir en fait donc il se fait driver
dessus driver qui peut pas tenir sur le
jour le porteur de balle adverse ce sera
un grand fan d'ac en gros voilà ils
n'arrivent pas à les stopper quand il ya
un drive du porteur de balle adverses
ce qui fait que ça met beaucoup de
pression sur le cercle est en fait il
faut passer des porteurs de protecteur
de cercles de qualité derrière lui et il
faut des ailiers capables de venir aider
sur date du deuxième rideau et tout ça
alors à une vie ça peut se faire aider
cossu créatifs comme à miami où comme à
milwaukee ou d'autres choses comme ça ça
se fait mais c'est sûr que voilà ça sera
comme lundi steve comme la tribune
collectivement dans l'appréhension
collective quand tu fais quatre ans on
reste ici en mal tu as tu avais pas mal
de choses donc oui tu sais faire les
rotations en même temps son rose sera
moindre il n'aura pas le même taux d'
usage donc ils prendront ils devront
gagner ces minutes c'est sur le terrain
dépendant tandis que là cette année en
fait on on lui dit un peu bon repose toi
un petit peu parce que il fait pas mal
de choses comme dans l' attaque de
georgia tech rôle va tout changer mais
ça peut se tenir mais après dans l'est
pour terminer les matches et tout ça ça
sera plus compliqué mais on parle d'un
joueur qui est plutôt destinée même si
pas mardi sur
6e 7e 8e jour de rotation si tout va
bien
ben c'est quoi son contexte idéal alors
allen a commencé à toucher le sujet
c'est quoi le contexte idéal de mike de
vaud son contexte idéal
texte
milwaukee de jouer dans une votation
vraiment quand même assez profonds le
8ème 9ème joueur peut-être amené dans
les situations précises façade et de
viabilité je me suis entendu mon chez
secoué les deux séries
face à tout ça lui et puis ils vont être
amenés à
sortir des équipes du trou ça dès
valence est à trois points à avoir
important de plus créatif plus tôt
on salue oselvar est aussi avec ses
cheveux magnifiques
et je ne vois ça je le vois comme moi je
crois pas qu'une équipe qui est en train
en pleine de creux définition des
besoins en jouant comme maicon de vaud
il faut passer peut-être par l'algérie
mais une équipe comme les box de
mentionner
qu mentionné à la noix que les heat ont
pas mal de joie qui lui ressemble plus
ou moyens donc ouais ça serait un peu un
contexte comme sun
city qui l'amena je crois avoir un
certain succès dans une ville aussi vous
rappeler
d'un joueur
bien sûr avec l'espérance entre autres
servir
est-ce qu'il a cette mentalité steve
parce que moi j'ai pas l'impression que
ça soit un fouteur de feu quoi j'ai pas
juge le voit rarement dans les grands
matches prendre feu et et être
l'étincelle pour ses coéquipiers comme
band vient de le décrire moi je le vois
plutôt comme un
repas partis en fumée il est tout le
temps là comme un leader d'attaqué d'un
leader d'attaqué surtout cette saison où
les parents tous réclament de super
joueur et sellas ou au rôle pour moi la
manière donc le projetant une vieille
routière et peut évoluer et que je pense
qu'il peut vraiment les leaders des
attaques d'une seconde une toile via
votre message est plus sur la capacité à
hawaï a joué 15 minutes ils 40 minutes
et a porté sur 15 minutes plus tôt que a
porté des coups de chaud sur trois
quatre peintures
d'accord alors ça implique du coup
beaucoup d'autres choses que tu dis ça
veut dire que toi tu le vois pas
seulement être un shooter mais aussi
pourquoi pas avoir le ballon en main oui
c'est en fait c'est sur cette saison qui
m'a convaincu il souhaite être capable
de ça c'est l'année dernière je le
voyais plus effectivement comme un
spécialiste du tir orthez du splitting
là je vois beaucoup plus être vraiment
au centre d'une attaque de ce green unit
d'une d'une équipe nba au milieu au
mieux voilà oui après après un petit
développement évidemment mise à niveau
comme dizaines de tas parce qu'il a une
capacité pas que tirs à trois points
voilà il est capable quand même un
minimum organisé ou c'est un minimum
depuis tout en 2d initiateurs met les
cannes quand même pas tous capables de
le faire il a il a une capacité à driver
quelle capacité à signer reproduit serre
grâce à sa technique ont des accents
avec les deux mains a dit cammas est
très actif il est très propre
techniquement ou
je pense que quelqu'un pression cette
année c'est que son usage d'augmenter il
est réussi malgré une augmentation de
s'auto 12 h il a réussi à augmenter ses
pourcentages au foot et y perdre moins
de ballons voilà ton coin sa capacité à
vraiment prendre une attaque et a essayé
voilà de performer avec alan on a vu ces
dernières années des joueurs qui sont
rentrés dans la ligue en tant que simple
simple entre guillemets role players et
qui se sont affirmés un peu plus tard
bah comme des créateurs de deuxième
unité je pense je pense par exemple à
josh art baquet même titulaire
maintenant mais je pense par exemple à
jo charte alors desmond bayne est en
train de l'être même titulaire à memphis
mais un niveau encore
toutes nos espérances et tant mieux
terence man tu vois du côté des clippers
et ce qui peut devenir c'est ce qui peut
avoir ce genre de destin est ce que tu
le vois à voir c'est comme auditionné ce
qui l'a le angel en fait et ce qu'il a
los angeles qui fait des différences
suffisante moi je trouve premièrement je
suis extrêmement frustré par le schéma
offensif de georgia tech j'ai presque
steve en pense mais en fait de ce que
j'ai vu je les ai vus contre georges hd
et vu contre elle et su je crois et je
l'aimé aussi contre eux yoann 6 et un
dernier match et en fait je trouve que
j'en peux plus de leur espèce de son jeu
avec l'intérieur et qui est il lui remet
sur un espèce de
fausse pick and roll et ensuite bas de
vonnas vie je vous dis sont passés de
peau de paul bling nadal implique
d'aller en voir à l'an dernier où en
fait il avait aussi la mauvaise foi est
qui qui je croyais dans le budget que
des clippers qu'elle était jour de
l'année choix moi ici c'est comme ça
donc peut-être que là il y avait huit
joueurs de l'énergie ouais c'est ça et
donc sur pick'n roll peut-être qu'il y
avait des choses cette année je trouve
qu'en fait on le voit avant c'est ça
s'améliore ip remonte ballon il ya plus
de passes décisives il est cette année
qu'un plus de 20% de possibles si je
m'abuse 21% 14 60 paires de base c'est
pas exceptionnel pour un seigneur fasse
mentir mais ça s'améliore c'est une des
premières fois qu'ils
les quasiment pas à l'équilibré c'est
différent plus de passes qui quittent
perd la balle en termes de pourcentage
bien sûr donc en fait je suis un peu
c'est un peu décevant en terme de
création pour les autres je trouve même
temps le schéma de georgia tech ça n'est
pas vraiment fait pour le mettre en
valeur on peut vraiment plus tôt le
faire sortir d'un écran le mettre en
mouvement et initie l'action mais il
agit vite la balance et on le met dans
un corner n'a vraiment compris je pense
que voilà allez qui peut qu'il dit parce
scoring il a pris il a pris 81 7 tirs à
trois points en 14 matchs pour 41% de
réussite
ils pourraient imiter comprendre plus tu
conviendras mourir mais mes choix sur la
création comme jamais sur un terrain de
man il eu franchement à florida state je
trouve elle était un peu plus fort dans
la création
d'offres a retenu c'était un peu
différent rôle de spécialiste et un
joueur comme max russe maks russe j'ai
été ravi de terreur que ça m'intrigue et
me faisait l'impression d'avoir raté
quand il était apte de paul parce que
personnes ont regardé deux poles en
réalité mais il avait plus de créateurs
sanaa regard jared à poil mais si pour
paul reed et roméo whims mai
mais est en fait si il faisait un peu
plus de création je trouve que devaux
et s'il a des capacités de création ne
sont pas mises vraiment en avant répond
c'est quand même tu sens cours
ben qu'est ce que tu penses de ça
j'aimerais que tu me parles de son deux
sont en deuil parce que je trouve qu'il
a des choses très particulière et en
même temps très très frustrant dans sa
manière de penser très gauche et en
règle générale ça exactement c'est
scarlett tragique il ya extrêmement de
gauche moi je trouve que
c'est plutôt ses côtés de courson le
côté distributeur de michael devos et
par l'initiateur
soit il est fonctionnel il est
fonctionnel il sait faire les photos il
est fonctionnel et aux actifs
c'est-à-dire la passe pourtant lorsque
la situation s'est à ce jour avec un
très très haut qi basket qui est très tu
vois c'est un gars qui aime beaucoup
jouer au basket qui fait passionnés par
ce qu'ils veulent toujours faire la
bonne lecture de jeu donc je crois qu'il
croyait quoi 2.53 passe par
trois passes décisives par match même si
son rôle c'est clairement de ce col et
dont on parle de quelqu'un qui lit bien
le jeu
moi je trouve je te vois côté en doses
ce qui le limite un peu vu qu'il est pas
explosif chez toi tu as le ballon
beaucoup ici au lorsqu'ils vont au
cercle il se fit beaucoup beaucoup sont
justement les stries capable de créer
entre déjà ballon pour être capable de
tenir ce genre de choses
c'est ça moi j'ai l'impression aussi qu'
il a il parvient à créer le déséquilibre
chez le défenseur je sais pas si je vais
être très clair a créé le déséquilibre
chez le défenseur c'est à dire à
surprendre par notamment il a un dribble
dans le dos de sa main gauche vers sa
main droite qui est très très
impressionnant pareil un dribble de
recul en prenant appui fort sur le pied
gauche vers la banque vers l'avant pour
revenir en arrière sur son pied droit
qui est impressionnant et puis après il
en fait rien il en fait rien ou en tout
cas il en fait pas grand chose est ce
que c'est un manque d'agressivité
steve ou est ce que c'est un manque de
tout simplement de capacités physiques
et dans ce cas-là ça changera sans doute
très très peu puisqu'il a déjà quand
même dans deux ans
on se fait plus physique
sur la mentalité surtout cette année où
là vraiment
également là les clés de l'équipe et il
a les capacités a effectivement créé du
décalage moi je trouve sur le premier
pas il n'est pas inintéressant que ça
ils arrivent à franchir et c'est vrai
que c'est derrière sur la ré
accélération ou sur la capacité à
changer de rythme et de direction ou là
on sent qu'il apportera un peu de mal à
vraiment profiter d'une plage créé
initialement pour pouvoir vraiment finir
en ayant créé une crise et par une vraie
entre séparation et c'est je pense que
plus sur le sur l'art sur l'aspect
athlétique que sur la mentalité sur le
magnet alan ben
pas côté confiance et qu'on dise pas
confiance en son jeu mais j'ai confiance
en son temps je voudrais lorsque
justement tu essaies de créer de
l'espace en faisant contacter si quand
ça fonctionne pas tu viens à croire que
ça comporte donc je te dirai peut-être
que justement un travail
marge de son concert poche ce qui pose
un possible je peux aussi vous rappeler
victoire la dispo entre oklahoma city et
il dit on ne la veux faire victor la
dispo et un meilleur l'atlantique
michael de vaud mais jusqu'à un certain
point
jusqu'à une certaine échelle sa route
vers sa plus grande michael de vos
meilleurs joueurs qu'il est présentement
je pense que c'est plus physique
physiquement oui ou la capacité à être
tranchant virevoltant son prêt pass créé
sa séparation là c'est un peu plus
compliqué peut il se rend pas les choses
extrêmement facile parce que il n'ya pas
là le corps mais il comprend il sait il
comprend les timings les ongles vous
pour les termes de patrick création
c'est comme ça qui réussit est très
fonctionnel c'est faire la bonne passe
quand la sphère t'as pas de jus donc ça
c'est
aller dernière question combien d'années
de carrière pour michael devant nba alan
déjà est ce que tu voudras 'ft' je crois
qu oui tu la donnes ton top 40 ouais il
est tout envoi de démontrer aux trois
monts qui donc aura entre entre 30 et 40
je pense racontera déjà et puis
potentiellement j'espère produire un
deuxième contrat donc on dira sept ans
de carrière déjà bien ouais c'est
beaucoup et j'avais des algorithmes qui
commettent faits qui montrent que sur 60
drafté en mangeant à 25 font carrière en
nba donc c'est sait déjà c'est déjà bien
steve bns que ce qu'on partage ses
pronostics jallet 6 mai
contre vaincu parce que l'on y va gagner
des peccadilles et qui après sa une
aujourd'hui ayant givré anglais équipe
en équipe par l'équipage jusqu à ce qu
il se tourne
je ne sais pas par celui m 3 par match
en euroligue ce type moi je vois bien
effectivement un moment ou un autre de
votre carrière elle en europe je pense
qu'il a le jeu il a le profil et moi qui
aime beaucoup le rollier qui m'a
vraiment le voir dans ce contexte là où
je pense que ça peut être un super
joueur hors ligue voilà avant avant cela
quelques années car n'diaye mais
j'aimerais bien le voir traverser
l'atlantique je suis tellement d'accord
avec vous je suis tellement
ouais c'est clair
mieux mieux à la doulou
faire mieux que d'arros le pape
catholique mais mais tu sais l'année
dernière je sais pas si vous en rappeler
ben je sais pas si tu avais vu
énormément de matches de de chengguan en
eurocup beaucoup trop c'était mais
c'était becel et il ya il y avait plein
d'américains dans son équipe la des mecs
un peu comme michael de vaud mais un peu
moins black mode et tout ça john berry
elle n'avait pas de frère aussi
g
c'est ça
mais c'est vrai qu'on espère voir
michael ii vaut peut-être un peu plus de
10 15 minutes par match un jour dans sa
carrière et donc ça passera probablement
par un passage en europe s'ils pouvaient
nous régaler sur sur l'euroligue où de
la bcl ou de l'eurocup ça serait pas mal
et pourquoi pas en france ou pourquoi
pas en suisse même s'ils n'ont pas de
club
en suisse comme son comme son oncle donc
du côté du canton du tessin puisque
c'était l'information principale à
retenir sur michael de vaud le joueur de
georgia tech qui est dans notre dernier
bord qui lui-même et sur notre site
envergure point c'est oh merci steve
darcis bel merci à l'âne et et puis à
bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures
nouveau podcast des like to each un
article par jour où ce que tu ne ris
porte par jour sur le site voilà il y en
a il y en a pour tous les goûts donc
vous vous pouvez pas rater ça abonnez
vous si vous ne l'avez pas encore fait
et partager notre page on vous fait des
bisous et puis ben prenez soin de vous
quand même à plus